six months after her sudden passing Lisa
Marie Presley's cause of death has been
revealed on Thursday the L.A County
coroner's office announced that Lisa
Marie passed away from complications
resulting from a small bowel obstruction
in the autopsy report obtained by people
it was noted that the obstruction was
caused by adhesions that had developed
after her weight loss surgery according
to Deputy medical examiner Juan Carrillo
the obstruction is quote a known
long-term complication of this type of
surgery the report also States at least
Marie was feeling ill and had complaints
of abdominal pain the morning of January
12th and after her ex-husband Danny
Keough took their children to school in
the morning he returned to find her in
Cardiac Arrest the report also reveals
that while in the emergency room Lisa
Marie had life-threatening heart rhythms
and a temporary pacemaker was implanted
after being admitted to the ICU for
further analysis a scan revealed that
she had already suffered a severe brain
injury
48 PM her condition dramatically
declined and she went into cardiac
arrest again before being pronounced
dead 20 minutes later Dr Creo also
specified in the report that Lisa Marie
had a distended abdomen for years and
that she did not seek medical attention
despite abdominal pain for the past few
months Additionally the toxicology
results concluded that levels of
Oxycodone remained in her blood at the
time of death Quetiapine metabolite and
antidepressant along with buprenorphine
which treats opioid addiction were also
present in her system but didn't
contribute to her actual death